So with the current happenings throughout the
manga and Sukuna deciding to cheat code the
absolute hell out of megumi’s body. IIII think we
should all jump back and look at the very first
time we witnessed the spectacle that is the 8
handled Sila divine general Mahoraga and this
monolithic creature battle against another ancient
figure inside of the Jujutsu Kaisen Universe. Yes
today we are re-visiting the one of the most hyped
battles to come out of the Shibuya incident arc’s,
15 Finger Sukuna Vs The GOD Shikigami Mahoraga.
OBVIOUSLY I shan't even need to say this,
but Jujutsu Kaisen season 2 and just massive
manga spoilers in general as who knows what
else I might allude to. But sit back and relax as
we watch half of Shibuya get wiped from reality.
So we don't exactly start off with just a straight
battle here, before that I need to go over the
moments that lead up to the historic fight.
Following Megumi's peculiar fight with his own
resurrected father he notices that the dudes face
has randomly changed back. Questioning why Toji
would’ve just done that, he pushes it aside to
focus on finding the others, only to be suddenly
assaulted by the luckiest creep on the planet,
Haruta Shigemo. The curse user slashes Megumi from
behind with his hand-sword cursed tool, dropping
him to the floor and seemingly ending his run.
After seeing what everyone else is
upto in Shibuya at a similar time,
we skip back to see that Megumi has somehow
manages to get back up and begun to hobble away.
As we learned early on in the series, the Ten
Shadows technique begins when a sorcerer receives
two divine dogs. Megumi explains that in order
to use the other Shikigami the sorcerer must work
together with his dogs to take down and exorcise
them. This way they gain more and more types of
Shikigami all with different types of utilities,
however they are limited to a maximum of only 10.
Wondering if he’s finished explaining
this useless information too him,
Shigemo explains himself that Nobara in his
previous fight was also pretty strong. To him
its surprising how young, but strong everyone is.
He knows that Megumi is already on his last legs,
still he doesn't see an opening to
get in and land the finishing blow.
Moments later as he just suspected though, Megumi
collapses to the floor after losing to much blood.
MAN ISNT DONE THOUGH, CRAWLING NOW HE CONTINUES
WITH HIS PREVIOUS RANT. So ya see guys,
the thing is you can actually implement help from
other people to take down a Shikigami, BUT that
also nullifies the technique’s ritual effect. For
a sorcerer it may seem like a pointless exorcism
with wasted energy, however my weebs even a
pointless exorcism is important if used correctly.
Weebs and Degen's alike do you all know the exact
reason as to why the Gojo family and the Zenin’s
are on bad terms? Obviously you don't it
was never explained before this moment,
only eluded tooo! According to Gojo it was
during the Edo period, maybe later but that
matters none the less, throughout that
time period the respective heads of each
household killed each other in a fight before
the aristocracy. Just like in todays climate,
back then the Gojo family had someone of great
power with the limitless cursed technique AND
six eyes. Still... they were taken out by a
user of the ten shadows technique like megumi.
Back in shibuya and in a moment of utter
despair now, Megumi bet that back then the
head of the Zenin’s probably used
this technique in a similar way.
Blah Blah Blah, fed up and done with
it all Shigemo just gets annoyed with
Megumi’s ramblings when ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE ENTIRETY OF THE CITY BEGINS TO RUMBLE!
Joke’s it isn't Megumi, just old Sukuna going
absolutely ham in the distance in his current
battle against Jogo. Shigemo is momentarily
distracted by the nearby clash between and
By the time he turns his attention back to Megumi,
the sorcerer has finished revealing his technique.
With his hands together he states that you
cant use a shikigami unless you exorcise it,
BUT YOU CAN SUMMON THEM ANYTIME YOU WANT FOR THAT
SAID RITUAL ATTEMPT! Not a single sorcerer to
ever use the Ten Shadow Technique had EVER been
able to take this creature under their control.
Realizing the mistake of his ways, Shigemo rushes
forth in an attempt to stop him. This time though,
and as the wolves begin to howl. Megumi
states. ‘With this treasure I summon,
EIGHT HANDLED SWORD DIVERGENT
SILA DIVINE GENERAL MAHORAGA’
Forced to take part in this exorcism ritual,
Shigemo understands he and Megumi have to
defeat the Mahoraga to survive. However, Megumi
himself knows that he’s far too injured and in
that moment he apologizes to Yuji for what's about
to come. Looking at his opponent Megumi mockingly
wishes him good luck as he'll be the first to pass
on here. In an instant, Mahoraga violently knocks
Megumi aside, sending him shooting into a nearby
building, leaving him completely incapacitated.
Turning around, Mahoraga sets its sights on
Shigemo next, causing him to panic and scream
for Megumi to wake back up. Sukuna who as I said
was nearby doing Jogo in, notices the situation
and while mid conversation with Uraume tells
his friend that he has to go deal with some
urgent business. Before leaving though, Sukuna
remarks that it really wont be long until he’s
completely free, then in a matter of milliseconds
uses his immense speed to rescue Shigemo before
he's crushed by Mahoraga’s thundering strike.
Rolling up next to Megumi he notices that the
kids in a suspended state of death, so pretty much
a coma. Thus in his eyes it was most likely a good
idea to save the fodder loser who was dragged into
the exorcism ritual. By rescuing the curse user,
Sukuna avoided ending the ritual, saving Megumi's
life. Sukuna confirms his hunch was right and
recognizes the situation Megumi is in. Sukuna,
concerned for Megumi’s health uses his reverse
cursed technique to save him while telling the
young sorcerer not to die as there's something
he needs him to do. To cement the safety of
Megumi, as man will die if the ritual fails,
Sukuna knows that even as an outsider to
the whole thing he has to defeat Mahoraga.
Initiating the battle against the 15
finger Sukuna, Mahoraga slams his blade
down causing the ground to begin cracking
under the pressure exerted on Sukuna and
sending a shockwave that blasts Shigemo back.
A weird energy begins to flow from the blade,
concerning Sukuna. Flipping out of the way, the
King of Curses avoids Mahoraga's evolving sword,
sending it crashing into the ground below. While
upside-down in mid-air, Sukuna delivers several
rapid-fire left straight punches to his opponent's
chin. Before he lands back on the floor, Sukuna
finishes his combination attack by using one of
his known cursed techniques abilities, dismantle.
Instantly its body is sliced with several
deep gashes causing the monolithic creature
to momentarily fall down on one knee.
Having taken the time to study his opponent,
Sukuna recognizes the shikigami's
weapon as the Sword of Extermination,
an infamous cursed tool used by cursed spirits
that emits positive energy. He even admits that
it would make short work of any normal cursed
spirit, however he isn't exactly normal.
Returning to the battle, the eight-handled
wheel on Mahoraga's head turns counter-clockwise
and suddenly all its injuries are healed.
Sukuna notices this and curious about what
could happen next, immediately attacks
with another slash. In an insane twist
Mahoraga easily manages to deflect
it with the Sword of Extermination,
surprising Sukuna as he notes that the
shikigami can see his cursed technique now.
Mahoraga prepares to send forth another
massive swing, and seeing it Sukuna chucks
up his guard in preparation. This time and
in a change of events, Mahoraga comfortably
breaks clean through Sukuna's block and sends
him crashing through numerous buildings across
Shibuya. With a ferocious speed Mahoraga
follows him into an office building and as
Sukuna jokes that he wasn't too bad, the Sword
of Execution pierces through the nearby opening
and takes the king of curses by surprise,
nearly stabbing Sukuna through the face.
In one of those holy shit I gotta duck moments,
Sukuna acrobatically flips out of the way to
avoid getting hit. He carries his momentum
into a spinning kick that connects and snaps
Mahoraga's head back. Dropping down, Sukuna
mounts the shikigami's arm before placing his
hand on his target's face and charging it with
cursed energy. Declaring that its his turn,
Sukuna unleashes a massive slash that cuts the
entire building in half while slicing vertically
down Mahoraga’s body, who is also sent crashing
out of the collapsing structure by the technique.
While Mahoraga is still shooting back in midair,
Sukuna capitalizes, following up with a powerful
axe-kick that sends his opponent crashing
several hundred feet into the ground below.
Believing he's properly deduced Mahoraga's
technique, Sukuna predicts it will stand up
and heal again shortly. Right on que, Mahoraga's
wheel turns and all of its injuries disappear.
Interested in the Shikigami, Sukuna notes
that first attack was kinda similar to the
mythical legend of Yamato No Orochi. While
its first attack used positive energy,
it adapted the second strike with
infused cursed energy that allowed
him to brake Sukuna's guard. Additionally,
Mahoraga was able to recognize, adapt and
deflect Dismantle. Both of these advancements
occurred after the eight-handled wheel rotated.
Due to this he can deduce that Furu's Incantation
of the Ten Sacred Treasures (which is the Japanese
folklore that Megumi’s technique is based
around) and that wheel represent a complete
cycle of harmony. Having taken his time to lay
out all this information infront of himself, he
comes to the conclusion that Mahoraga's technique
is the ability to adapt to any and all phenomena.
Remembering the time he first fought Megumi,
he admitted that if he’d unleashed Mahoraga
as originally intended during their fight
when they first met, it probably would have
defeated him. Amused, Sukuna thanks
Megumi for showing him the way and
activates his Domain Expansion,
the prolific: Malevolent Shrine!
When it comes to the Demon King himself,
Sukuna has two types of slashing attacks.
The default slash, Dismantle. And the other,
cleave which can be adjusted depending on the
targets toughness and cursed energy output to
cut them down in one go. Most people throughout
the series and the universe of Jujutsu kaisen
often make a domain expansion by realizing
their innate domain and surrounding it
with a barrier to give it structure.
Malevolent shrine differs from every other type of
domain expansion as it doesn't create a separate
space using a barrier. Get this, like this is just
how insanely ahead of everyone else Sukuna truly
is. The ability to take your domain and realize
it without using a barrier for structure is like
an artist trying to create a masterpiece.
Not a simple canvas masterpiece, no this
is like someone painting on thin air, a truly
divine technique bestowed apon a demonic force.
Furthermore, Sukuna customizes Malevolent
Shrine with a Binding Vow that allows an
escape route out of its effective range.
As a result, the pact also increases the
maximum radius of Sukuna's domain to two hundred
meters. In order to avoid hitting Megumi though,
Sukuna narrows that down to about
one-hundred and forty meters.
Letting it loose, Sukuna states that
until the technique is deactivated,
Malevolent Shrine will relentlessly attacks
anything in range. It will cut down anything
with cursed energy using Cleave and destroy all
inanimate objects with Dismantle. This results
in massive devastation on a city-wide scale.
This takes the lives of numerous civilians
who thought they were safe hiding in a building
during the rampage outside. Outside it not only
decimates Mahoraga over and over and over
again with an endless barrage of slashing
attacks but over a hundred-and 30 meter
radius of Shibuya is constantly pummeled.
With buildings and pretty much the entirety
of Shibuya falling to bits around him,
Sukuna believes that the only way
to actually defeat Mahoraga is to
slaughter it with a new attack before it can
adapt. In his eyes cleave fits that criteria,
still... if it hasnt adapted to Dismantle
specifically but to slashing attacks then it
only leaves him a few moments to attack before
Mahoraga’s re-generation will be complete.
In order to finish the fight, Sukuna decides
to unleash the mysterious pyrokinetic ability
he used to defeat Jogo. Instantly after opening
that weird dimension or something, Sukuna fires
an immensely powerful fire arrow at
Mahoraga before it could fully regenerate,
creating a giant explosive pillar of fire from the
impact that completely annihilates the shikigami.
After the dust settles and while completely
immobilized in awe, Shigemo watches as the king
of curses walks over toward him with the wheel.
Throwing it next to the pathetic child, Sukuna
watches as the wheel ends up disintegrating,
signifying the conclusion of the exorcism
ritual. Wondering what the freak next to him is
looking at, he tells the curse user to be gone,
prompting Shigemo to flee in joy. Ecstatic that
he somehow escapes with his life again. The
reason for this dudes insane levels of luck
is because his technique actually stores
up a number of miracles. The little everyday
miracles are erased from his memory like they
never happened then stored for when his
life is in danger. The markings under
his eyes signify how many miracles are stored
up, weirdly enough though and continuing with
the theme of Shigemo just being a nutter,
he isn't even aware of this simple fact.
Then like even more of a nutter he runs
straight into the devastation of Shibuya
not realizing that Sukuna’s domain expansion is
still active. In fact he’s actually used up his
techniques remaining luck throughout
his battle with Nanami and because of
that Shigemo's body slides apart, having been
completely sliced in half by Sukuna’s domain.
Back over with the king, man notices that
he doesn't have much longer to control
Yuji's body. So in the final moments he
sneakily rushes Megumi to the Shibuya
Tollgate where Yaga and Shoko are so
he can be treated. Immediately after,
Sukuna returns to Dogenzaka and
relinquishes control over Yuji's body,
asking the young student to take a good look at
the destruction that took place in his stead.